today's episode is brought to you by
gray block pizza gray block pizza it's a
special kind of place do you like that
kind of place then you should go there
it's in Los Angeles on the way to the
beach
18:11 Pico Boulevard gray block get that
hitter today's guest is a comedian he is
a man that I actually don't know super
well I'm happy to have him here he's
from another continent I believe I'm not
sure all the different continents and he
and he just has a lot going on he's
about to go on an Australian tour tour
he's been around the world doing
stand-up he's achieved many of his
dreams and now he's he's hosting a daily
talk show here in America even though he
isn't from here ladies and gentlemen mr.
Jim Jefferies
[Music]
and how tall are you man cuz I was just
I woke up this morning I was thinking of
myself I was like alcohol is good well I
have to wait but I'm they be had me at
like 510 but I'm almost 6 1 yeah why do
they I feel like someone just took a
guess at that or maybe 5 9 they call me
yes I have the appearance of a short
person yeah I'm all torso got little
tiny legs yeah what is that you think is
that like an Australian thing I'm s I'm
a sloucher as well my posture is not
good but now I'm quite tall yeah were
you always tall like when you were young
around shortest member of my family so
my like like a suit out of my siblings
yeah my parents have quite shorter than
me but my brother's six for mother
brother six two or three and do they
like you your siblings they do they like
me but they don't like each other really
yeah they're getting better they're
getting better they didn't like each
other for many many years I didn't talk
for a well over a decade and I think and
do you mediate that kind of stuff like
oh yeah it's all through the power of
stand-up I do a show in Sydney they I'm
only there for one show that their
friends want to get tickets and so so
they all come backstage and then that's
when they started talking and backstage
at my gigs really yeah without my gigs
they wouldn't have they wouldn't have
met up again I don't think now it would
have taken a funeral yeah and and is
that a popular thing in Australia like
girls love them oh no ha ha ha
brothers don't get along like a lot of
um no I think that's a popular theme
across the world I don't think it's a
distinctly Australian thing I think
Americans have is probably more family
rifts in America because you have
religion thrown into the mix yeah I'm
sure that doesn't help and this is where
it was Thanksgiving weekend and I'm sure
people are going off to fight with their
family or dreading it yeah yeah there's
a lot of domestic domestic violence and
stuff like that I think it brings
families together in the end you know
what the domestic violence well it
usually like the violence is what kind
of quails the heat they the heat is
before the violence the friction is
before the vine yes you need to have a
little blow-up yeah you gotta have a
very block I fight with my fam
time constant but do you find on skype
or do you guys fight on that on the
phone well I we have to fire on the
phone because with my parents cause they
can't text or anything you know but like
like for instance I I I'm bout to to
Australia and my brother like the whole
reason behind this Australian too is
because my brothers getting married so
I'm going it for his wedding and I
agreed to fly my father across the
country business class so he could come
to the wedding Wow yeah
and so from Sydney to Perth which I
because I was doing the tour I could
have gotten it in the the Qantas
responded like helping us out with the
tour and so they I could I could have
gotten a good right and I kept the same
don't worry dad you just have to shops
at the airport and the ticket will be
there yeah don't worry about it and then
he started the panic started to panic
and three weeks ago now the weddings are
not until another two weeks from now
three weeks ago at the fear that the
flight would be sold out he went and
bought a ticket Wow
on the airline that month and so I had
to be far with him I'm like I was
getting you the ticket as well you could
just pay for the upgrade now I'm paying
for an upgrade right that was more
expensive than that so it's just you
know where did that come from
oh people do that kind of stuff they
want to be sure like my stepdad will get
to the airport he'll take my mom to the
airport two hours before yeah and they
live in a small city in three hours
international it's crazy what is that
because they listen to when the
government tells us [ __ ] and the
government goes okay because it you know
I have to get there three hours before
in case there's a holdup
yes only an hour you have to get there
an hour before I dated an attractive
woman who who she wouldn't go into like
20 mins before and I was always told I
couldn't get on the planes if I wasn't
there like 50 minutes before yeah she'd
always still get her luggage put through
and everything it was bizarre to see
chicks get that yeah of bizarre to see
we might you my dad had to have and he
couldn't fathom the idea that he just
showed up with his licence you had to
have the paper ticket oh yeah so he went
to a travel agent can you imagine Kenny
going and sitting in a booth with a
person going they'll on the door problem
yeah where you go you go I'd like to go
on holiday are well here's some ideas
you could do this or that imagine like
how is that only exist the job only
exists because of the elderly yeah
because they can't fathom another way to
do it but like it's even more work than
doing it yourself
oh dude it
I haven't I mean look the elderly are a
whole it's a dirty business what people
do to the elderly where they still keep
them selling them gold like you know oh
yeah so I do think that in your country
yeah there's a lot of gold there's a lot
of reverse mortgages Oh reverse
mortgages are good relation to the guy
your safety is not going on it's not the
kids don't need the house you live now
and you thing and as the fact is they
could just sell the house moats they
selling everything dough son I'm a
[ __ ] moat will come and dig a moat
around I got a a moat yeah they sell
everything all type of land who's
getting moats not a lot of people but
I've seen a couple you know who Adam
senior citizens dude it's always seniors
they got everything they think that the
moat will stop people from getting into
their prop fires stop
yeah weak burglars stop people that you
know maybe different types of animals
think about it right so if you live on a
farm you get a moat then when you have a
bridge that goes down oh I don't know
you have a car you have a solid bridge
it's always there I think you'd have a
solid bridge I mean if your senior
citizens you can't have them you know
looking for like a button to put a
bridge down in the middle of the night
oh yeah but it's great the stuff they
sell the seniors man everything special
clothing fire like the big thing now
there's someone to an America's fire
resistant stuff get this fire resistant
clothing fire resistant I got my mother
a life alert necklace one of those ones
with a button that the ambulance comes
out you never seen my dad more
disappointed I was lucky sentenced to
just had five years added to it like he
literally looked at it like this you
guys so the ambulance will always come
up now all right okay all right this is
what we're doing you know III got a
sheep my mom's got like the the Bentley
the rolls-royce of Walker's mm-hmm I got
are the most expensive walking oh really
what is it now when you get to those
upgrades what is it like what other
thing is the cheap ones like 20 bucks
and your top ones like 800 oh wow but
it's got like oh the frames lighter or
it clicks in properly or I just said
look what's your best one you've got
okay you can't put your mom on a bad one
well I can't I like like I think they
already put the tent those are those
tennis balls they put on the end of
walkers yeah that's sexy that's appeal
yeah but it's gotta be someone's gotta
just actually make those balls we can't
just be cutting into tennis balls just
make a rubber ball that
is over the end yeah the green does my
make it a nice black matte finish but I
think there's something swaggy about its
like how black guys kind of hang their
pants down you know I think it's kind of
that has that sort of fur you know right
so you think that the old people like
yeah I know the tennis ball trick yeah
it's got the street credit kind of
because otherwise there's just rubbers
on the end is that make it like means
you move it faster because the tennis
ball glides maybe the felt of the tennis
balls where it's out as well and the
silence I think a lot of old people
don't like a lot of sounds yeah you know
probably and that's another thing I
think they're gonna start selling old
people like soundproof areas and like
soundproofing like I mean it's just
crazy soundproofing and moats yeah I
reckon I gotta see one of these modes
yeah it's even pulling up on a house man
yeah all right yeah dude and this is
this was in they I know they had
something your Birmingham when I was in
college but see what you study I don't
know man I think electricity uh you
study electricity no communications home
might in America these are British moats
you're showing us yeah these are old
these are castle moat everyone knows
about them I want to I want to do recent
I want to 2018 most residential tomorrow
no 28 a residential moat you know he was
a premature baby you know yeah I can
talk yeah do recent moats please Nick
there's one is that one yeah there's one
right there
that's your google search term man
recent roads everywhere sites are you
gonna do unbelievers hard to get good
help or any there's one there's one
there's right they look quite pretty
yeah that's an now that's a nice and
that's a rich guy that's a guy so
[ __ ] younger that's not the swimming
that's a swimming mode
yeah what do you have do you have a nice
place here now what are you I got a
house in suburbia I live in suburbia now
I got a nice house he's live in the
hills but I wanted to have a place I
might keep the rotties bike and you know
so I live in the in the flats now in the
valley
near my kids school yeah less than half
a mile away from his mother inside
everyone's very close and there's that
still a marriage you still married or no
no no no yeah we're never married right
I've never been married
did you uh when you go back to Australia
for this tour do you does that feel like
what does that feel like is that feel
kind of different than it's going on a
different like tour in the u.s. it's
what I'm doing I'm doing arenas so
that's different
other theaters here in America for the
most part yeah and so I'm done arenas
which is different also
I sort of Australia was the last place
for me to crack you know I was working
in Britain so long and then I sort of a
crack Britain and I cracked Canada and I
cracked America and then Australia was
the last place and so you know but I'm
Way more popular there than I am
anywhere else down yeah so I you know
and that sort of happened I just I I
guess I have to thank the internet
because it wasn't anything that there
wasn't any big move to do that and
Australians hard-to-please is there a
reason why I took them so long to come
come along I just think that you're you
sort of you see what you want you know
like up until 10 years ago YouTube
wasn't what it is now you know right and
people were just watching whatever you
we would give it on the TV yeah before
Netflix was showing specials like you
know I did an HBO special
ain't no Neer's ago it didn't really
reach Australia never got aired in
Australia was an HBO here I think the
British Comedy Central bought it yeah
but if it did get in Australia I didn't
know about it so no one saw that special
in Australia but then Netflix was like a
big thing where you record something and
then it comes out straight away so my
last three specials have been uh Netflix
it's probably got a lot more to do with
that yeah but I what I do enjoy is when
I first came to America some comics were
a bit skeptical of me I heard I heard
some snide comments about me being that
it was all the accent and it was just
saying come to us well some people think
it's a fake accent yes so they go they
think it was the accent that so I take a
level of pride knowing that I sell so
many tickets in Australia where the
accent isn't charming at all it's
exactly the same as everyone else's
that's
so it can't be the accident parent they
don't know it's the accent that's not a
big trick to them I'm not doing anything
I'm not doing any little trick so you
don't sound different there no in fact
now because I've been so long in the UK
that my accents got a little hint of
British and I don't think I got any
American in me but I do have hints of
British overtones and it is you off a
little um not really
I like the Brits I think they're cool
bunch and I just live there on my 20s I
think I still primarily sound Australian
anything any British president's listen
to this thinking I sound like I'm
English but when I go back to Australia
I come from a working-class family and
everyone's like or someone speaks like
the Queen right look at this fella
alright someone's a bit fancy yeah
someone's got a recent moat that one's
got one of those new motor stopping
people kidney there forget cauldron on
the fence
do you like Billy Idol that's a weird
question I don't dislike Billy Idol I
like him I think if Billy Ida was in
concert and I was it was like one of
those like 80s [ __ ] package things
really I would be one of the people I'd
be looking forward to seeing yeah and I
like how this shows I'll name it but I
remember I remember when the wedding
singer came out we were like Jeezy's
aged well then he would have been 50 and
the wedding singers gotta be 15 years
old yeah oh yeah
so he's gotta be pretty easy 70 yeah I
think he's maybe yeah I don't know they
kind of stopped putting her age out
rockers do it like about 60 I think yeah
but he I saw him about a year ago and it
was great I saw him with Morrissey who
[ __ ] God was the worst but I the
boring it just bought Jesus boring we
know you've got new songs and you just
drab and boring Billy Billy 62 village
62 that's I don't believe that a but he
looked awesome and he was rockin bro
he was rockin yeah I look you just four
white wedding alone you go alright or um
yeah what's another song of his that I
really love [ __ ] the city that always
reminds me a movie big last night a
little angel what's that one came
dancing through my door oh yeah I know
rebel yell yeah oh yeah that was awesome
man have you gotten to meet one of your
idols read to me Paul McCartney once
that was cool um that was just he was
just at the improv and I think a lot of
comics so it's sorry cuz he hung out at
The Improv for a while
yeah and Brad Pitt I know you guys I
know Brad Pitt but I wouldn't say Brad
Pitt's a hero because if I was an actor
maybe but like right and I'm good
friends with Russell Crowe I've been
friends with him for about few years oh
well he is and we hang out together and
he's a real good dude and Brad's just
the sweetest bike ever and helped out
and was on my TV show and you know I
think but like as heroes when I when I
record him and I special I got offstage
and Chris Rock was in the dressing room
that was pretty cool that was like a
hero nothing got to me Eddie Murphy at a
birthday party really was it a
children's party or an adult was um it
was James Packers birthday but I do a
routine on this with James Packer who
who is half half of the production
company Rat Pack mine owns all the
casinos in Macau he's a billionaire but
he was at the time was engaged to Mariah
Carey and where I carry threw him a
birthday party and I was the hired help
and Eddie Murphy was one it was the
dinner party any Murphy was a dinner
party and you would perform it I was
doing stand-up for 20 people and my
childhood here I was sitting there and
do you feel at that point like does it
take you out of like oh I'm like a you
know a good comedian at that point
you're just like puts you right back to
the early days of gig like I sent you
you regress back into like oh god I
can't do this what am i doing what am i
doing I'm just dinner hell yeah because
no microphone is standing there at the
end of the table telling jokes to people
who didn't expect you to be that it's
it's suicide
yeah it's it's a terrible experience
Edie well I did it with the express
thought that this could be a weird story
and it turned out to be even weirder
than I thought it would be yeah but I
did it like sometimes especially since
you know I've always told stories am I
staying up and then I was at stage I was
in a relationship with my son's mother
and so all like one night stay in
stories and drag stories that went out
the window you know I mean so then I was
like where do you find these experiences
I think if it wasn't for my son
wouldn't have written my gun control
routine because just right now yeah so
for the first time I love I started
talking about the world you know yeah
but like I remember like if someone gets
Mariah Carey wants to book you for a
party I remember thinking oh I should do
this because this could be weird did
party you think you might have a chance
to hook up with her like someone your
head she was booking me because she was
engaged to a guy who was a fan like she
wasn't a fan oh yeah I was the birthday
gift for a fiance there's no part of me
that thought I'll hook up with Mariah do
you think they'd hire you to do some
late night activity or something cuz
rich people can get like that you know
no no I didn't I didn't think that they
wanted me to do anything like that I
wasn't I wasn't in their sights for that
I would have been up for it but I didn't
I didn't get an offer
have you ever had a like you know be you
know we can take this out you ever been
in a place where you had to be sexual in
front of some other people that were
watching I've been involved in an orgy
yeah oh wow I was scared of that I think
I'm never nervous never been in a
threesome
I was in a threesome one time in Indiana
and that made me pretty nervous so
you've done it well I've been in I've
been in maybe five or six races and you
get the hang of it or something after a
while I think I've done two of them
where I've done a good where I'm like
this is everyone's sympatico here and
we're all getting along and yeah there's
nothing worse than being the third wheel
of the orgy yeah there yeah yeah yeah
where it's like where it's like your
girl just wanted to shag another girl
who she liked and then you're just sort
of off to the side like that episode and
Friends you know I've been that guy yeah
I've been yeah I've been an OG where
where where the other two guys it was
like four girls and three guys oh there
was other guys and yeah yeah but this is
what four guys and build the mofo yeah
four girls three guys I think yeah I
remember the other two guys at one stage
and this is many they know you were Jim
Jefferies or not ya know what they met
me I organized everything I met I met
everyone at the comedy club I was good
right I got it all set up but then what
happened was in my early 20s the other
the other guy was a comedy promoter and
the girls were his friends and then two
of the other girls were just girls we
met and they were both friends and then
the girl you got to let the girls decide
you don't say this is what we're doing
it's got to be you can drop a joke in or
something I've got to be the
decision-makers in the whole thing yeah
and then we're like okay so then he's
the promoter had a mate there and he was
really really good-looking and the
promoter was this really buff sort of
black guy right with a big dong on him
really you know and he was good-looking
too oh wow and then I was who everyone
was trying to hang out with because I
was funny but then we all got naked I
became like the least popular person in
the room right all right and so then
like you're the waiter yeah yeah I'm
getting people drinks and trying to keep
the the atmosphere light changing their
thermostat anyway then eventually but
this is this is this is me my probably
not now but I mean I mean everyone had
come a few times and the girls want to
keep going and I was the only one who
could still get an erection like you've
never seen him work more furiously on
the other two dicks like surely this one
still works and and I just sat in the
corner when you're done with those ones
yeah there's still one open we're
working overtime here with Mel Gibson
yeah I did um yeah one time I got caught
up with these girls from Indiana but
they didn't know each other right and so
and it was like kind of a hurried
experience because I had to go to the
airport and like yeah that's weird with
everybody strangers yeah it's been
they've been there and I always trying
to like introduce these girls like
literally we had like nine minutes to
make it all happen so it was like trying
to have sex and you know kind of
introduce these girls you know do small
talk
at the same time like oh so you know
like I was literally having sex I
remember I mean like oh so you know of
you guys you know do you guys go to the
same you know gym or anything you know
like just it was very bizarre and one of
the girls kind of looked a little bit
like you know like somebody that used to
do weightlifting like in the circus
remember those people that were real
strong she was very barrel chested yeah
polis like she would hold a barb that
had 100 on it you know like she had a
curly moustache a shaved head
he's wearing stripy [ __ ] pajamas yes
he definitely uh you know had operated a
train you know like an actual cold like
she got better things like like you look
at those old things with whites and
there's like we'll put the white in the
end we'll just make them flexpays-- yeah
well make him like like balls balls of
white no no one like how long did it
take for people to figure out we can
make these into disks smaller yeah and I
we used to be the look of it that's why
I guess you wanted to see somebody look
like they were doing something I was
talking to my friend forest the other
day about yeah Forshaw foreshortening
who opens up for me everywhere he's
coming to Australia with me and I need
all these gigs um we're talking about
we're talking a young a comic who's
staying at my house at the moment from a
stroke or a must kill and he couldn't
remember a time when there wasn't cup
holders in the cinema and we were like
no no no no no you used to have your
soda
yeah and just put it on the floor yeah
hey baseball games I really put it on
the floor like like huh the first time
you saw a circle at the end of your
armrest didn't you just go alright we've
done it but crack that well this is it
we're cracked it and you're sitting in
cars yeah that was an internet with
drinks drinks between your legs driving
the first person to go like it's so
close to the wheel our first convention
it's so close to the wheel and then it's
like cup holders on the end of things
like we were [ __ ] yeah what's up wheels
on suitcases
carrying bags we we invent like carrying
bags my dad would have like two bags
another bag wedged under his arm and be
waddling in and my mom would be hurting
me and my brothers and not sweating as
much either remember like back then you
never said it wasn't now everybody's so
sweaty and they're not doing anything
yeah well there's definitely that just
happens because I like I understand like
we all the real fat people is well I
want to be one yeah if it wasn't for the
health problems
and just looking gross oh I would I
would love just to eat whatever the [ __ ]
I want and not move I don't want to move
do you think in the future like we're
like where do you see us kind of going
in the future like do you think we'll be
leaving our homes as much or do you
think like people are locking in so much
right now that I think I think we'll be
getting a pill that just [ __ ] make
sure that anything could pass through
and you can eat as much as you want
that's the big that's the big revolution
of mankind just eaten whatever the [ __ ]
you want and then I don't about moot
about moving and traveling and stuff
like that I don't know I've traveled so
much in my life that I don't need to
travel anymore don't need to see
anywhere else in the world but I think
for everybody else I think it's
important to see the world it gives you
a better view of who you should be and
how you should treat others and how some
our countries are doing it better than
you and how lucky you are to live here
and well that type of stuff it's good to
experience well and you should do it
when you're young I think yeah I think
you should do it when you're young and
carefree and you can [ __ ] shag and
get drunk and stay in a hostel and stay
in a hot you should do it then
now I likely didn't have to do any the
hustle stuff with his I moved to England
and then I got to travel through the job
so even when I wasn't anything much
money the hotels were always good allow
so yeah I'd go do kind of working I'd go
do Dubai or Asia or something like the
gigs were booked out of Britain
they'd be paying me $400 for the gig
yeah after all that trouble but I'd get
the free trip and I'd get the five-star
hotel so that made it worthwhile but
after I did a couple of times I didn't
need to do it again right is there a
place that you still go that are like
internationally you're like oh that's a
place that I'm definitely going all the
time I'm still gonna still perform in
Holland about once a year
Wow I do like a little bit little okay
5,000 seats sort of raining Tom Rhodes
loves that area yeah yeah yeah and so so
I go do do Holland I can still sell
tickets in Holland all the time when I
go there and I still love to do London
whenever I can
right you know I do London every week if
I could my favorite really is the
audience there's something special about
the audience server there people always
tell me I get a huge response from
Australians like on social media and
stuff like that they've been so like
welcoming but what about the UK is there
something for the UK for me personally
because it feels like
tangible goal that I achieved because I
started out there in comedy clubs and
then to move into like bigger rooms and
then to play the rooms that I used to
see bands and concert you know I mean it
was just something that was really cool
and it's I just I just know London top
to bottom I know where they hang out in
the CD Club if you want to cheap beer
and I know where the fancy places are
and everything in between it's just it
feels very much like home to me London
yeah yeah but I just became an American
citizen so Wow
yeah my episode tonight no Wednesday's
airing next Thursday mixer well the
episodes already a I get I get sworn in
by Eric Garcetti here Garcetti the mayor
of um who's the coach of Niedermayer
approach of the heat the mayor of
essential mayor of Los Angeles yeah the
Honorable Eric Garcetti I believe by the
time we done with his podcast comes up
maybe in a week's time he will announce
that he's running for president that is
that is my belief and what vibe that you
get from him meeting him well I said to
him I said are you gonna run for
president because I knew he was talking
about he goes I'll have to decide the
next three weeks and then you guys but
someone's got to get rid of this guy and
then he winked at me Wow
for what about getting rid of try I was
like Dan so I think wow so I think all
right this guy's guy very charming i
wagered on him to get the DNC nomination
at fifty to one yeah or 25 to 125 to one
yet how long ago did you do that about
four or five months yeah all right so I
think now you'll be looking 10 to 1
mm-hmm Wow
the odds were to drop I got I got value
would you ever do you start to thinking
like a you know since like you said I
mean that you know this is kind of your
first bachelor where it's like a where
your things weren't about you know as
much stories and stuff like that it was
special I didn't mention politics at all
I mention it all in the other ones that
no this one is his last special I did go
back to stories and stuff because I had
the separation from my child's mother
and all the moving and stuff from
becoming a single dad so I had a lot of
stories like that but the two specials
before that were a lot more political
and stuff because I was just living
family life you know
have a lot of stuff going on besides
comedy or whatever and and I did sort of
get interested more in politics and you
know like the the gun control routines
really why I have a TV show I think that
people responded to that that much that
I think I think well i one thing I do
well in stand-up that state trying to
put onto television is I think I dumbed
down difficult subjects quite well mmm
then that's not through any trick right
I'm just [ __ ] simple yeah a lot of
people need they just need it in a way
where they can consume i I think I give
palatable arguments yeah do you think so
if not guns like what weapons should
everybody have that you think would be
fair well I don't look I'm me personally
you know I mean everybody's got one gun
everyone's got one do they I don't know
I think so
do you everyone not yet but yeah not
everyone he's waiting for that guy
steady money yeah like our steady clock
he's so great you win money on him being
elected and you get a gun and commit a
crime there at least two out of three
yeah so when we know by win-win way when
were they announced that I I don't know
I don't follow up closely enough like
all the pre stuff
where'd you find gambling on that I just
buddies a bookie and it was on there
guys are not in there anymore but I bet
the rock would run for office I bet 200
won that the rock would run for office
about a year and a half ago I think I
think 2024 does it um do you gotta study
okay so then what are the odds of him
winning uh it's probably about almost
double that cuz fronting Trump is like
he's about 50/50 yeah do you feel like
your movie that you became like more
like a like do you feel like you fall
like more like as a Republican or a
Democrat have your I'm a socialist
because I grew up in socialist countries
so I believe in health care for all and
housing for all and I believe they
shouldn't be homeless people on the
streets I believe the problem should be
taking care of
so so I because of my socialist views I
would lean more towards being a Democrat
but I you know I would have probably
been closer to what a financial
Republican when I was Australian and
when I was British then this but like my
views on guns and my views on abortion
and gay rights mean that I am a Democrat
but if you take those fundamental things
out more for smaller government and that
type of stuff so I have I have some
I have Democrat opinions with some some
Republican ideals or the other way
around yeah it's like there shouldn't be
only two choices
yeah well that's what Ari Shaffir was
saying recently no Ari yeah he was
saying recently that if if 5% of the
population votes for a third party then
that party gets equal funding as the
other two parties get and so that that
would start to at least you know lead us
in that direction because then up that
party would start to have money to be
able to uh to put a name out there I
thought well there was a third party in
Britain a while back and then they had
to two of the parties had to merge and
that third party just seemed to be
pushed out yeah yeah Lib Dems it's gonna
get wicked man out look I think it's all
gonna end up in WWE it's all gonna end
up in the ring doesn't it feel like that
a little bit well it does because it's
all a circus now but I feel like now I'm
probably saying that in 1960s
yeah you know they're probably probably
in the nineteen sixties when I would
Kennedy and Nixon are going this is a
debate on television yeah it's just
become a circus now that was the first
time there's a televised debate and then
at family they shot that whole family
Kennedys whoever did it man you know
people in Dallas but they shot Bobby too
right I did yeah they shot him yeah - I
mean if two of the brothers get gunned
down that's like the Earp's that doesn't
happen since the IRB's I don't think
yeah they the Kennedys they're funny
Bunch they keep trying to do the one
thing that kills them yeah now let's go
back and do that occupation that kills
us so like like the two of the brothers
died and then the dad tries to push the
third son into it
and like
kills a bird in the river yes he drives
a car from the river and kill yeah I
know I know her her son is a comedian me
or her yeah her cousin is a comedian
that girl's cousin right so this guy is
it Ted is it Teddy or whatever yet
Teddy B jr. know what are we looking for
the person who killed someone yeah Marco
it no it wasn't no it was um yeah I
think it was Ted Ted Wright said Ted is
a movie about it right but Ted drives a
car off the bridge why he's drunk into
the river
killed dies he gets out of the car just
assume she's dead tonight she was living
in there for like 12 hours or so closing
the roof yeah anyway yeah so they're
like oh you'll never be President now
Teddy it's like why the [ __ ] he both of
his brothers have been already shot and
killed at that point like who the [ __ ]
is going I'll do that job dad like like
it's sooner or later I know you
shouldn't give in to fear you shouldn't
give in to it
but sooner or later the dad must have
gone okay alright like the dad buddy
stage he was like he was like a
vegetable he's just like getting run
around with presidents it's like [ __ ]
you guys he's probably giving his
daughter a buzz cut gonna send her in an
office right do you think we'll have a
lesbian president in our lifetime or not
um mmm a lifetime a hot one no no right
yeah I think you know I don't think
we'll have a hot lesbian in charge of
anything busy making me do chores for I
mean to do anything like that I'll just
play by them houses yeah but I do I
think I well I think we have a gay
president within my lifetime I don't
believe so I know we've already got gate
we got a gay governor in one state just
got voted incorrect we had a guy and a
lot of these dudes are being secretly
gay and doing stuff Oh everybody done
some you're telling me Mike Pence hasn't
been in some prey the guy never listened
in a [ __ ] Amy Manning of the oh she's
painting some probably the guy right
thing you can just say it allegedly I
had a thing where I got beat by
- they have this these to have this
thing downtown these two Vietnamese guys
for 70 bucks would [ __ ] you up you know
they put you in this outfit and these
guys will [ __ ] you up and for 70 bucks
it sounds like quite the bargain why
would you pay that those used to stop
you being gay no no this doesn't do that
I don't think I mean I didn't I was
inferior just give me an erection he'll
be well that's what happened to me one
time came during it and I didn't expect
that and I and I've never been gay I
mean I you know like I had some dude pay
me like maybe 40 bucks to look at his
[ __ ] once when I was a kid but that's
not I don't know what that's art that's
art but what happened Garba 40 bar yeah
but but the thing was what I'm saying
was I didn't expect to get like a
feeling out of that that was kind of
that live and be up sexually mmm you
know like sometimes you don't know where
you're gonna get a feeling that's gonna
lie you really did you really pulling my
leg no nope on your leg so you paid to
Eisenberg's to beat you up
Vietnamese yeah why well they would [ __ ]
you up in the they put you in a suit and
it was kind of like uh what's this suit
like kind of a you ever seen a dog bite
suit pull up aa dog like like okay like
you're a consumer yeah that's right yeah
but a nice one not a sumo wrestle and
that was for Paul I know though I know
the one I'm being chased down by a dog
you run those outfits exactly like that
Britney visit the military yeah these
two guys would [ __ ] start kicking you
and beating you right okay so what's the
point of that to get the feeling of it
just made you feel like a man made you
feel like a it made something come out
of you that made you feel it made me
feel strong it made me feel some pain it
made me feel something you know right
and $650 for that suit too so they had
to get at least ten before they made
their money back in that whole venture I
have six ever really the dry cleaning of
the inside of the so yeah yeah are you
Republican I think I just got on the
melody you're a Republican I think when
I was growing up I was probably more of
it I guess I think I'm kind of the same
as you I think in some ways I I have
some ideas in some ways I have other
ideas you know I you know I'd liked John
McCain I am not a big fan of Donald
Trump yeah I mean so there's there's
people you can pick and choose through
the party that there's this Democrats
that I'm like that
about as well you know there yeah I
think I would I
I can vote now I think I will vote
Democrat yeah yeah go well so this is I
just feel like just for social issues I
can't I couldn't be a Republican for
social issues yeah and did that start to
change or anything when you had a family
no no no I've always felt this way is
probably strengthen my ideals but I I do
believe we are in in danger of of that
letting the left get carried away and us
looking like wending [ __ ] you know I
mean like there's a lot of pusseh
fication of the left yeah that isn't
really helping you cause if you were
more moderate you could get more
Republicans and so it's like it's like
guys are my dad's generation you want to
tell them like being gays alright gay
people can get married and it's taken
amuse they're on board now yeah like
okay I get it
alright I mean they are I get it it's a
bit quit telling them you're quick okay
okay so you've got them on that they've
all accepted that they're voting for gay
people gay people get and then and
they're you like now here's a
transsexual yeah and it's like alright
alright calm down
they just did the gay thing here yeah
and I mean and if you don't like this
transsexual in your a transphobic way
and then they're just feeling attacked
they're like I've just gotten used to
men kissing you just gotten used to that
and for years I was bigoted about it but
I've come around yeah and so so for me
it's like we have to grandfather some
people in on their views agreed you know
I mean like like there's got to be okay
this is bad that's bad but the people
over 90 yeah people over 100 be racist
yeah
all right over the hundreds oh you
cannot yeah if you live through the
Second World War and you can vividly
remember it I mean you deserve to have
some views up yeah you can have some
views I'm not gonna say you're right or
anything like that but if you're over a
hundred I'm not gonna try to change it
yeah you're just like a book almost
that's the thing so I'm giving a hundred
year olds racism okay there can be
racist
that's fair go to town both both ways
right yeah are people over 80 I'm giving
you I'm giving you home
yeah I'm giving it to you I'm gonna see
it it's been a while you had taught at
school that it was a mentally you had
taught at school that it was a mental
illness yeah right so I'm gonna give you
that people said you shouldn't do it
when you're growing up so it was like
almost yeah even your parents everybody
was like probably skewing you away from
it yeah yeah yeah and it wasn't so so
and the guys you did know a closeted or
not there's a service so you didn't
really know about this world and so I'm
giving over a tease
over 70s no more homophobe you can't be
homophobic anymore because you're my
parents age and you well I remember your
growing up with you and what the world
wasn't like that and the 80s was
fabulous and the thing you know what I
mean like everything was fine right I
agree but if you're in a way if you have
a couple conditions though if something
happened to you if you're you know maybe
every now and then there be next there
being a rarity well ya know of course
there's exceptions there okay good but
70 you know IVA see I have a Cerveny you
can be trans phobic I've decided that's
it right over 70 yeah 70 of you can be
any trans because that one's a big leap
for some of them 70s a trans is a big
leap because it's starting to just like
you said just [ __ ] bother pee it's
just like you're not using nor for me
and you it's fine yeah and we know
comedy people I know transsexuals yeah
and there's no issue with it whatsoever
but the generation before that was I
know gay people and the generations
before that was I know black people yes
they're all right right so we're working
our way through now anyone 70 or under
you don't have an exclusive or anything
if you're in your sixties and below you
have to sort of be tolerant of people
and you have to get along I'm not giving
you any more isms yeah you can be Andy
fat right if you're in your sixties you
can get you can fat shame yeah fat shame
okay yeah I wish I have a 50s you can
[ __ ] shame yeah still be a little bit
like I worked on me life and she sat at
home [ __ ] this person yeah yeah
everything and then 40 down my
generation went no more excuses no much
no excuses it's all over but they'll
find something else and find something
else that we think we thinks normal yeah
that we that we thinks not normal
anymore you know I mean that'll be
normalized I don't know what it
and yeah it's everything now it's like
but I I agree with you on the part where
it's like I grew to on all of that and I
agree with you on the part where it's
like yeah they just keep finding
something else it's like a lot of people
just thought of okay trans that's that
and those types of those people you know
people that are trans or people that
have different you know have sex changes
and you know not sure what sex they're
in people just kind of lump that in with
gay sometimes I think in their mind as
they learn to accept it yes so then
people started like getting specific on
the word it's like yes it's wrong maybe
to call some of this trained if you call
them gay but it's like [ __ ] somebody
can't spend their whole day studying up
on what is the okay thing to say your
sexual identity and sexual preference or
two different things I get that and I
understand how it can be but like now I
think it's in Canada's over 20 different
names for every 70 isn't 70 names and
now the thing is I don't get what I
French fries these things I don't give a
[ __ ] you I you I will call you whatever
you want to be called yeah well ever you
want to be called
I don't care but I also understand the
people who are like but why should I
have to do that and the answer is what
does it matter right just call her what
they [ __ ] won but I also understand
the admin yeah why should I so you got
your Jordan Peterson's in this world who
I sat there and found him to be fairly
reasonable sort of fella idea he was in
here I did it I did a section with
Jordan where I I about the it should a
person be able to deny baking a cake for
a gay couple right right
and he goes there's a difference between
should and shouldn't they they should be
allowed not to do that but is it right I
don't believe so but they should be
allowed not to do that right oh my gosh
should they allowed to be allowed to not
make a cake for a black couple and he
goes you know what maybe you maybe
you're right maybe you're right maybe I
was wrong on that one right and he
admitted he was wrong right away and
what happened was all the people who
watch my show her extreme left we're
just like yeah [ __ ] suck that you
[ __ ] dick Jim Jeffries proved you
wrong and I was like that was a cool bit
of conversation yeah that was the bit
where he
you can say did something and then the
people on the right started to attack me
like you ought to try to make him look
like a [ __ ] idiot
[ __ ] you yeah I think both me and him
had like a nice normal moment a normal
moment where we saw eye-to-eye on
something and the guys obviously much
more educated than me he's he's alive as
he's a lot unita me so so for me to to
win a little argument with a simple
concept felt pretty good you know I
won't lie to you I was like that was
cool but but it I die I didn't do it I
didn't air it to make the guy look like
an idiot yeah and then people were
started going going you edited that down
yeah yeah we interviewed him for 45
minutes in with the piece was five
minutes right and he knew that as well
yeah he knew going he knows how to play
the game yeah he also has a type of like
that he enjoys the controversy of the
people saying oh they edited you wrong
you know I mean yeah that's his kick in
life that's what he loves he loves the
debate yeah yeah he likes that whole
thing so I don't think it hurt him and
anyone but I don't know how I got onto
this I was about the twenty different
names or the seventy you're telling I
thought it's twenty when I did that
interview was twenty or thirty years and
see a lot of voters will then say if
there's some and then a lot of I feel
like Democratic candidates feel like
they have to then support all of these
agendas you know all of these lit you
know they keep getting more specific and
sometimes just bothersome to the point
where it's not helpful it's just
bothersome and a lot of a lot of people
will then vote against them just because
of that people just want to get through
their [ __ ] day yeah yeah you know
you're picking them one little tiny
thing and you might be cutting off your
nose to spite your face because you're
so angry about abortion that you're
gonna get your [ __ ] taxes if I can
take it off for you and they might you
know and most people don't care about
those old topics people go keep going
back to these old topics and racism and
all this like dude I grew up in
Louisiana my father's from Nicaragua you
know my mother's from here but I grew up
in Louisiana and like there was racism
both ways I got a new just as many black
people it didn't like white people as
vice versa do you think do you think the
next step because I just watch that
documentary and that girl who she
thought she was black what's her name
Rachel though right she does after you
see the documentary yeah I don't agree
with her doing it but I get why she
I get where she's coming from she's from
an abusive family they adopted a whole
lot of black kids she though very young
she sort of took the kids away tried to
give them a what you would call how I
know that bringing where they would know
history and stuff like that she got so
entrenched into it and sort of started
to feel like these were her real
siblings rather than the pet family she
came and so like a Stockholm Syndrome
almost okay and so she I don't think she
believes she was black but she
identified as black in the same way that
I don't think translational transsexuals
they they know they have a penis even if
they think they're a woman they still
know that the what the history is yeah
and I think that after watching I was
like man I don't know if that is much
different like if that might be the next
thing that people get to decide what
race they identify with yeah I like that
you know I mean like I I think it's
stupid but if it's a solution you said
to me 20 years ago 20 actually more than
that 25 years ago you said to me though
someone's born a boy should they be
allowed to be a woman I go that's silly
you're a boy this big a what difference
does it make yeah I would never have
thought you know when it's 15 or
something that's somebody wanted to go
through to wish them well yeah yeah Who
am I like I'm comfortable being a
[ __ ] white Australian guy I'm alright
with a transsexual yeah yeah but I don't
like the fact that it's like we and I
think is why a lot of people have
started to go to podcast because people
aren't allowed to talk anymore in a lot
of other circles and and a lot of that
type of stuff has also been why you know
people just deserted the news and like
Trump keeps the news in business more
for Trump I think the news is dead
24-hour news channels like that I got a
fill-in but no but the thing is 21 news
is bad used to fill them with smaller
stories we used to get the story of
there's a child missing in Kentucky yeah
and they're always ease there's always a
charm but we never get those stories now
all we focuses in is these big picture
things where the president says
something stupid I'd like smaller news
yeah I would like some [ __ ]
you know even some some nice stories
where a dog is raising a chicken yeah
and they're surfing yeah I always don't
like that on the news
or somebody like caught if somebody had
the biggest pumpkin that was always a
good one yeah yeah yeah biggest pumpkin
yeah yeah I want to hear about the local
farmers markets and what's going on in
my town yeah how good are the chives
locally um but it's but at the same time
it's been yeah it's been interesting
like for for a lot of my life I thought
there was nothing socially that was
making me feel any [ __ ] vigor or
anything you know like we had the you
know the Persian Gulf War when I was in
school and but you know that made you
kind of feel like this American sort of
vibe but outside of that there hasn't
really been a lot of the Persian Gulf
war in Iraq that didn't make you yeah I
mean I guess I think those kind of in my
mind's eye got 11 yeah there are 11
didn't ya 9/11 spark you up yeah I gave
you the lift in middle of a game to lift
that here but I think maybe like uh yeah
I don't know I guess there just it felt
like yeah there hasn't been a lot in my
life whereas I guess if I look back at
other loads in your lifetime yeah we
haven't not been at war that your entire
what is 30 38 38 okay so he's 38 in your
lifetime you've had the Gulf War the war
in Iraq the war in Afghanistan you've
had probably the Berlin wall has come
down you have had the market crashes of
[ __ ] epic proportions the biggest
since the depression yeah you have had
you've seen the first black president
yeah you have seen that was falling of
the Twin Towers yeah you're right [ __ ]
you haven't seen World War 2 or a real
good assassination yeah no you haven't
seen a real good assassination like yeah
I mean you thought that I saw a guy gets
shot off a Claver in one time in New
Orleans during Mardi Gras yeah but I
haven't seen anything big you know no
III went out I went out to Iraq and
Afghanistan you at the heart of the war
it was it was no [ __ ] [ __ ] man it
was going down yeah yeah we were being
shot at and helicopters flying the gigs
Wow
yeah
it was something it was something we saw
the death of Saddam Hussein yeah we saw
we saw the rise of North Korea yes true
Oh guys [ __ ] you've seen Briggs it
you're around for brexit yeah that
seemed pretty crazy huh I wish I'd have
been over there no I was over there
whenever you early I was in in the
country when it happened was it exciting
no one you they still don't know it is
like the people who did it when they got
their vote through and they won they
went well well I've done what I need to
do I'd like to retire now and it's like
you're meant to be steering the ship now
can you have to do something yeah
because they don't know if they have to
bring all the people back from Europe
they're all the English people who live
in [ __ ] Spain and France and I top it
up whether they're being kicked out or
they have to get rid of the Europeans
who already live in Britain so you've
got to get rid of all the nurses and
staff that work in the NHS which is like
80% people from the Europe but they're
not gonna be able to pull that off are
they no I think what they're doing
they're doing a moving forward I think
they're leaving everyone where they are
because I think the only thing that's
really changing is the lines at the
airport which they're idiots they used
to be a Briggs it needs to be the the
the EU and they have to fly through
anywhere they land in France they fly
through now they're gonna have to join
the line with me no yeah the Australians
and all that none and I know it's gonna
be longer idiots idiots they should have
never left yeah but there's you know
there's people who think that they're
better on trade or something like that
now you already they already had there
are the only people in the European
Union with different currency yeah they
had the pound everyone else is on the
euro and now it's just I I don't know I
don't know what they're gonna do now is
it more exciting for sports though you
think because everybody gonna want to
beat them now
everyone always the the the Brits a
notoriously bad winners yeah the bad
sports oh yeah they they beat they beat
with a behavior world
they beat Sweden in the World Cup and
then when they win and they went in and
kicked off a [ __ ] IKEA store yeah you
won yeah like when they beat us in the
cricket when I was out there in the
tournament called the ashes which is
the big tournament happens every few
years Australia vs. England and it's the
only one that everyone cares about and
they won back the ashes for the first
time in like 30 years they want it back
and I was out there I would get booed
all the way from Australia boohoo they
hated it they hated it and they won and
so then I said I I said I said to the
emcee I said tell him I'm from New
Zealand so I won't get booed they go all
the way from New Zealand Jim Jefferies I
went up and did my say bucket and boom
Wow Happy Days and then halfway through
this big burly New Zealand fella stands
up in the middle of room he goes he's
lying he's not from New Zealand because
we can tell the difference we know
accents Yeah right he's not from New
Zealand he's an Australian and then the
audience hated me even more because I
was a lying Australian do you are
Australians gonna be upset that you're
an American citizen now I just posted it
and some people one guy wants a refund
from my shows and I'm still Jul
citizenship yeah I just thought my life
would be easier having two passports and
be better that way you know and I mean
but I mean um yeah one got you're dead
to me can I have a refund on my tickets
but it's like you're taking your talents
elsewhere I could see that a little bit
like you're taking your talents
elsewhere you're taking your talents
down to South Beach you know like when
we're on the Brawn left Cleveland the
reality of it is when I was up and
coming in Australia and even when I was
saying big theaters I wasn't really
welcomed at the Melbourne Comedy
Festival and I wasn't ever put on any TV
shows in Australia and so I don't I did
it all by myself
building up my Australian market and odd
type of stuff I didn't get help from any
of those festival types and they can go
[ __ ] suck my dick yeah you know like
I said I still love Australia man but
like but the promoters and that enables
the promoters weren't very there was
always the level of shame involving me
because I was this wary guy mm-hmm that
I don't give a [ __ ] what you say biggest
Australian comedian ever yeah
no one's ever like the standard wise no
one's ever come close to Chris Lilley
he's not Santa he's not staying up and
pull Hogan's gonna stand up and you know
I'm not saying the comic talent but for
stand-up comedy no one's ever really
cracked it yeah Gallipoli this is the
only thing I can think of after you
and that's not gonna come back that's a
war movie Crocodile Dundee young guys
I'm serious you're right man
you have you met Chris Lilley no but
we've talked a few times on on social
media I think I think the guy's a genius
but he's he's now over Korea's over
wholly quit no no no no that's the way
no no no the media has just decided that
with all the blackface on so stuff
because he does yeah agent Faison
blackface an Italian character and on
top of stuff which may I say the BBC
which is Australian funded programming
couldn't get enough of the guy but now
that now they've just dropped him just
gone on no no never heard he's he's the
best
yeah his humors the problem with things
and he racist on cyber stuff so he can't
get arrested in Australia right now but
HBO sort of dropped it as long as HBO
kept on buying a new series yeah and
everyone just acknowledged that he was a
comic genius and that he was really
smart and now it's like oh no no he's
comedies racists well we all watched it
when did this happen because in May he
had a Tenten they announced a ten-part
series from Netflix from him oh they do
you say Netflix might be back on but
Australian TV started going you know in
believable no no I
Australian TV was like the start he
started doing articles about how he was
what's wrong with comedy I don't believe
that I think I think he's very funny I
just watched our summer hearts are the
best things that's ever been mine I just
watched it this year for the first time
I just learned about it and is I could
not stop as the best thing I've ever
seen next to like America's Most Wanted
yeah it's it's a fantastic comedy yeah
and just the mr. Jake character is one
of the fun and the key and like I grew
up with kids like that man kid from
chong'er and and and and the private
school girl and also dad yeah yeah
because his dad's always looking at his
dick stop look at my dick is so specific
- yeah you know dude it taught me so
much about the Kyle earned about the
culture sitting there watching I bought
into the fact that he was a Tongan gay
you know like yes and then they did the
thing well the thing is the kids you
know from Chong and stuff sometimes they
hadn't done a lot of schooling before
they get to Australia so they are a bit
more rough and tumble and I mean so
there is that that sort of trope you
know
but no but it but I thought it was it I
didn't think I just thought that it
seemed it introduced me to the fact that
they even had those kids know we have
these islands all around Australia and
it's like Hawaii it's like a real
faraway Hawaii yeah so we have a you
know and so often they come over to the
mainland and you know yeah yeah oh some
of the greatest our rugby players
greatest rugby league plays are all like
from Tonga and Samoa yeah and what type
of stuff and also you can [ __ ] around
all you want in a nightclub in LA and
you'll get kicked out or whatever but I
tell you what in Australia we have the
biggest doorman in the wallflower we
have some [ __ ] Manuel beat the living
snot out of you name any club in Sydney
yeah Sydney we have a couple of
questions that came in from viewers that
we're gonna get to real quick it won't
be about Chris Lee and in Netflix that's
exciting
yeah that is awesome what do you think
you'd ever work on something with him oh
wait I would love it with Chris Lilley
me too yeah I would I'm putting out that
Chris I'll work with ya me too and I
could do soccer doopy I'd probably pee
out at least PA yeah yeah
or carry drinks yeah today's episode is
brought to you by Ridge wallet Ridge
wallet it's a front pocket carry you
ever seen somebody and they can't read
can't even breathe whatever what I'm
talking about is the ridge wallet the
ridge wallet is a way for you to carry
things from the your back of your
pockets in the front of your pockets a
lot of times if you look at movies or
drawings and stuff from the 1600s you'll
see people have wallets in the back of
their pocket or they even have a big bag
of money and a gun well this is
different this is a ridge wallet you
carry your credit cards and you carry
your your license and the things that
are most important to you and you keep
it in the front of your pocket it's that
front pocket carry they've been with us
for a while and I use one myself
in fact I got all my stuff together
right here on the ridge visit ridge
wallet calm slash Theo and use code th
EO at checkout for ten percent
that's code th EO
for 10% off at Ridge Wallet dot-com /
Theo today's episode is also brought to
you by skills share a lot of times I
don't have any skills you know like the
other night I was looking I was trying
to get some ice cream you know frozen
dairy and I got some out of the freezer
but I couldn't get it out of the bucket
because it was too hard and I only had
plastic silverware so I gave up and put
it back but things like that can be
different if you go to Skillshare calm
Skillshare is an online learning
platform with over 20,000 classes in
business design technology and more you
can take classes in social media
marketing data science mobile
photography creative writing you name it
they got it some of the classes that
this past weekend listeners have signed
up for include Facebook Ads for
e-commerce trap music production and
ultimate Ableton Live 10 part one the
interface and the basics I don't even
know what that is but I could if I
wanted to at Skillshare calm what is
separating you from your dreams is it a
skill you can change that whether you're
trying to deepen your skillset or just
start a side hustle you can get two
months of Skillshare for just 99 cents
that's right this past weekend listeners
Skillshare is offering you two months of
unlimited access to over 20,000 classes
for just 99 cents if you're tired of
your Instagram stories look and budget
look at Mucky then get on there for
$0.99 take a class how to make your
social media pop bang bang go to
Skillshare comm slash Theo again go to
Skillshare comm slash Theo to start your
two months now hey what's up CEOs
lamia going to Houston Texas I'm a huge
fan but I got a question for mr. Jim
Jefferies also huge fan I know you're
upset or you're kind of fathered by out
back because they don't call the shrimp
on their menu prawns because Allen I
said that's what I'll call them but I
lift it up and prawns and shrimp
two different types of like animals
there's no more looking but they're
they're super different so that might be
why but anyways my question is how's
your campaign you don't people do hoist
of the Outback anyways I hope you have a
great day thank you very much is it true
yeah I I sent a few tweets out I'd like
to be the voice over that backstay cast
I don't know who else they're getting
just [ __ ] give me the job yeah now
the different dream there between a
shrimp and a prawn right okay prawns are
bigger right but when you say jumbo
shrimp
that's a prawn yeah so this is [ __ ]
prawns all right and it seemed perverse
to be looking at shrimp that closely to
me yeah it's like one different [ __ ]
claw and I'm saying like that but jumbo
shrimp are prawns and so we can have we
can have little tiny prawns as well but
yes I I don't like that the are back
steak house has no Australian food on
the menu yeah none nothin you think
there'd be a meat pie or an Australian
desert or something they've got nothing
you have an onions not Australian onion
is not is not a strain but I will say it
on an advert you know Outback what are
you doing yeah I'll do the advert they
don't even call you bogans when you run
out on the tab either
that's it
they don't do [ __ ] man I went into one
in Atlanta we were doing a field piece
it was like I'm in the suburbs of
Atlanta huh and it's way up and the lady
thought lady thought that I was just
doing the accent it's like the piece cuz
you never had an actual Australian
coming though yeah she thought I like a
you like my accent she goes I've heard
better gone in there and done a
different toilet no I said they had a
black lady call me the n-word at a wall
files one time in Atlanta and I honestly
thought it was kind of cool actually
why'd she call you though I don't know I
think was just like really hot weather
you got a name or net yes right
right how would you do it really hot
weather did she go right in words yeah I
wouldn't shoot when I was over in food
yeah yeah it didn't used to be you know
sometimes I think it was thrown around a
little bit more in just conversation a
little bit more before it became such a
an emblem of I mean there's always an
emblem of tab
you know but though there was like uh
you know if you just use the soft a at
the end people would use that a little
bit more a little bit more socially
sometimes I think even in the last 10
years at 7 yeah yeah it's different I
think a lots going on I love the idea
that you said about about people decide
and what gender they are because there
was a tie I mean I think especially most
white kids from the age 11 to probably
16 or black you know yeah you know I've
heard that in I might be wrong but in
heard from some gay friends that this is
a problem in the gay community at the
moment is that because everyone's coming
out so young all they've got was a load
of bottoms and they haven't got any tops
Wow look like they're losing the macho
man [ __ ] closeted guy he would just
sneak in there in the bathroom and then
[ __ ] the [ __ ] out of here yeah and a lot
of them are attracted to that guy and
that guy doesn't exist anymore because
everyone's fabulous damn right I used to
like the burly closeted ones yeah oh I'm
sure that hip man yeah I'm gonna had
that Paul Bunyan yeah that was more of a
[ __ ] you know the Brokeback Mountain
sort of guy really did you gone in a
taint you know that guy you gotta have
that Paul Bunyan that sneaks in there
and gives you that polar paw
sounds like some opportunity for someone
someone who wants to clean up but
they're on the other side but they're
like yeah if you're if you're a burly
cowboy sorry [ __ ] Lenny Dykstra get
your [ __ ] you know yeah there's some
great opportunities I feel like yeah I
think because it's become some gay men
it's become more of a they want to be
more like an ornament like a Christmas
ornament then they wanna like there's
not as many you know badass gay men kind
of role models I don't think are you a B
Vin Diesel yeah I mean I think I don't
mean in a negative way I think he's a
beautiful man I don't care what he does
here you know it's none of my business
but rights on the alleged right but we
need some more gay men like that we need
a gay [ __ ] bastard ugly Jon well I
think we I think okay so if Y didn't end
manic game hmm
right it's a lot right but then in the
acting world it turns out there's like
one in 30 yeah this that's don't if I
can head out and
and guys are attracted to that industry
all right I'd studied musical theater at
university yeah it was all gay people
yeah and so so I would like and same
with our athletes everyone come out
that's the best thing you do everyone
just [ __ ] have a come out day where
we all [ __ ] do it yeah and then it's
just like oh that guy never thought you
know but I think people are worried to
learn acting this too worried about
whether they can do action movie roles
or something like that or they can be a
lead man because the people will know
because like Rupert Everett gave er to
go for a while yeah you're being Diddy
4.5% US adults identify as LGD B
according to Gallup yeah that's four
point five people at but it's higher in
men homosexuality is hiring me I heard
it was 10% of men now do you think some
of it do you think that that's gonna
grow do you think some of it's just part
of like what's going on and are
scientifically over time like it's just
part of just some no I think there's
already always been this many gay people
in the inner society oh yeah the
proportion it's always been like this I
remember it was fun when I was yelling
the East have game in the East have a
restaurant called Shoney's you know
Shoney's restaurant yeah and it was like
kind of like a kind of like a nice kind
of [ __ ] kind of and they used to
have men would go back there and hook up
and make out with each other or behind
the rest area by the interstate and so
it would be fun for us to go watch and
like kind of you know you know it was
like that you know not aggressively
watch you know just watch and but it was
fun to go see that kind of stuff occur
you know it was more of like a fun thing
to see and then now it's like
everybody's doing it sometimes you know
it feels overdone sometimes yeah I don't
know if it's it's overdone if you want
to see it you can see it it's got into
West Hollywood it's everywhere III I
remember when I was a bartender in
Sydney when I was like I'd say nineteen
I always really enjoyed when gay people
came into the bar cuz they tipped well
yeah I mean live in the joint up they
live in the joint out there they're
always friendly and [ __ ] happy to be
out and yeah I always always liked
having gay clientele yeah yeah I think
it would be tough to feel like you have
to be constant like yeah wonder if
there's this chip on some gay guys
shoulders that they feel like they have
to constantly act more gay than they
feel like they are you know and and I'm
just saying this out of like a general
question and you know place of
vulnerability I don't have any idea you
know it must be wonderfully freeing to
be like that it must be wonderful right
yeah be like so overtly gay I think
would be a wonderful sensation yeah I
think cuz then that's when you really
accept that who you are and you don't
give a [ __ ] what people think because
you will get judged yeah there will be
some what are you at some party is
bigger to do you if you're so overtly
gay will say something behind your back
it must be wonderful just stop giving a
[ __ ] yeah I wish I could be myself and
use my actual American accent I've gone
too long now let's get to another one
Nick yeah and I just want the 10% off
decided from the Kinsey study in 1953
right uh a lot of sources think that's
like a little high no all right so right
11 yeah all right I'm fine with that
yeah here we go to go 7 well I think I'm
three percent gay myself oh yeah I've
seen a couple of things but here's a
question though honestly did you notice
at all in the past maybe you know 20
years your life they used to sit more
like this and now you sit more like this
right and then all the rage I've started
to yeah what is that bro that starting
to happen to me that happened to me
where my father was sent like this what
do you think of varicose veins and his
legs and I've ever [ __ ] surgery so
it's probably not probably not good for
you yeah you got a on sit like that man
but I was never never been at this guy I
always been in sort of oh that's insane
brother middle airplane guy yeah I don't
I don't I don't like people to do the
man sprayed that's not much though I I
do this mostly still to this day that
fits you yeah this is nice this day but
every now and again I do the full cross
now I never cross left over right you
don't that's madness right over left
yeah that's much more comfortable yeah
good radio Jesus okay let's take another
shot here that's a incentive for people
who just listen to watch the YouTube
so here's the next question say yo
what's up big dog cam from Ohio
currently living in Tennessee
Jim Thanksgivings coming up is your
mother going to talk about having polio
as much as she was always able to bring
it up when you talked about it in your
special
that's pretty Oh love you brother Jim
you're hilarious keep doing your thing I
love you guys so much talk to you later
my mother must have it she had polio you
don't you get cured from it oh she beat
it
yeah there's no polio anymore in the
free world that's all eradicated oh wow
but that's great it's like with these
parents not back saying the kids could
have a comeback one day do you think it
was a necessary evil no one could have
done without Paulie to wipe out young
kids
no it wasn't bring it up bring it up
it killed people killed children man oh
man nah man I'm out yeah my mother was
bedridden for years
oh man I'm sorry geez couldn't move in
ever since there's still a bones are a
bit funny from the polio I'm sorry I
know that no no all right do jokes about
my mother's my mother came to bring up a
picture yeah I don't mind I just don't
have to read all the images of people
polio pitches okay so your legs go
unlike little kids in a school and was
contagious they'd have brackets on them
and yeah the bones don't move again and
they have to learn how to walk it and
take it down yeah it's not good it's
still it's still in the third world yeah
it's not good it's a [ __ ] contagious
as well I could still get a beat it it's
a kind of a thing but we did beat it we
did we can vaccinate against it okay
good we have a vaccine okay good I catch
polio okay good all right all right um
so my mother probably but now my mother
has Parkinson's disease and she's so
happy about it is she oh my god she's
already she's like 77 but easier to have
probably oh I don't hit sir no because
she loves being ill by the time it hits
her properly she'll she might be long
for the world anyway yeah I mean but
she's like she's just being diagnosed
and
she's [ __ ] taking medication all the
time in the nervous systems [ __ ] I have
theories on Parkinson's disease and
people might be yelling right now in
their car that I'm wrong but it just
seems like I heard Michael J Fox was a
cokehead [ __ ] Richard Pryor was a
cokehead he had it yeah Dudley Moore was
a cocaine Trixie and they and they all
got the same sort of rare nerve disorder
of the brain that no one can quite
explain how I'm like it seems pretty
like it's cocaine yeah well it's my
mother wasn't a coke a but my mother
taken a lot of medications for other
things a whole life so she's always been
a big fan of the pill poppin yeah oh you
know is she pretty loving your mother's
you're pretty loving he's is a very
loving woman but she's also very we've
had our fights over the issues she was a
hard she was a very strict mother too
and and quite violent yeah but we've
we've talked about it recently we've
we've had words and we've we've come to
terms with each year yeah he was very
nice been very liberating it's only
happened in the last year my life dude
that's funny the same thing happened to
me yeah yeah I just had a big
conversation with my mom the other day
that was like I didn't even know that I
needed to have you know yeah and then
she kind of like we both kind of
realized some things and it was just I
mean I it was liberating yeah I I
realize now that she can't remember half
that oh maybe three quarters of it she
can't remember it because you block
things out everyone's the hero in their
movie and you don't realize that you're
a villain in many people's lives you
know I have exes the villains of mine
and then I'm probably villains of theirs
or
I mean when you think are you [ __ ] me
over or whatever and so so for many
years my mother was a villain some
stages in my life because of some
physical abuse that I've suffered you
know and but she since apologised I was
more the yelling as constant being
yelled at as a job yeah I was yelled at
before I was spoken to just gone and I
wasn't I wasn't a bad kid and I and I
thought I was a bad kid back in it now
and I'm like I wasn't a bad kid at all I
was pretty well behaved kid wow that's
funny man to hear you say that cuz
that's exactly some of the same stuff
yeah like I think my mom didn't speak to
me in a way that was loving first that
let me know I could be loved and instead
there was this other tone that made me
unsure what I was how I was felt towards
I would go from being your the best
little boy in the world and you're a
perfect child a toaster - you're a piece
of [ __ ] and it will happen within an
hour and so even to this day I still
have like this arrogance about me where
I think I'm the best comic or whatever
like that and then I think I have fear
before I go onstage my mom [ __ ] I'm
[ __ ] hopeless you know I mean like
like I still have these highs and lows
yeah I could see that still don't feel
comfortable with myself where I can hang
and just sort of I don't have to impress
anybody or I don't have to show off or
anything to have Worth and you know that
all it all stems from your childhood it
all it all stems from that you know I
dated someone who who her whole thing in
life was people think she was pretty or
whatever and if they didn't and she was
really angry and so she would manipulate
and try to bring down other girls around
her and stuff like that you know and
then once I learned more about a
childhood I was like I didn't want to go
out with her anymore but I sort of got
it right you know I got that's what
where she was always from a young age
that was what was told was valuable to
her yeah and so so I'll say this both me
and my brothers are very successful we
came from a very poor family with very
working-class family and and I I will I
will say that my mother is the reason
for our success she put a definite and I
don't know if it was a healthy thing but
she put a definite fear of failure into
us where it wasn't an option
mm-hmm and that that if we turn out to
be losers
and then it was just that would be the
worst thing in the world
wow that's interesting yeah it's funny
how like yeah it's like you probably
needed that whatever occur you need
I still I still everybody success I have
I still have a certain level of well
[ __ ] you that'll show you and I'm
yelling now I'm just yelling at the
[ __ ] wind yeah I I get given a TV
show that oh sure yeah yeah is fighting
with anymore I have no one telling me
that I can't do things and I'm saying
well I did it though yeah yeah it's
weird these sometimes he's just these
things we have going in our head these
patterns that are just existing in our
head that we don't even realize
sometimes you know that's the scary
thing is sometimes look like I'm trapped
in some patterns that I don't even
realize you know that aren't super
helpful for me but what's your pattern
is actually helpful I think like just
being up like my toughest thing is just
being in relationships being able to
feel other people's love for me you know
it's really really hard and so then it
makes it like it makes me feel like a
loan a lot of times even though or not
cared about a lot of thumbs even though
I probably am so it's not that people
don't care it's that I can't be take it
in somehow you know and so so yeah
that's this this thing it happens to me
a lot and then I get depressed and
bummed out and you know and then the
relationship I'm in will end because
that's the dark is your yeah you're
upset about the whole thing you're in
your head yeah alright I still I I don't
do as many misogynistic jokes as I used
to I used to do some very misogynistic
jokes and I always stand by oh I'll
stand by him in the sense that I knew
they were jokes so and the reason I sort
of suppose I started to get bothered by
the people who were getting the blood
laughs out of it who were laughing for
the wrong reason but very clearly I had
some issues with women and and that the
problems I have and still struggle with
is that my experience growing up women
were the main ones yeah you know what I
mean you were in trouble with them and
so that shapes relationships I mean now
where if they start to get a little bit
mean or hard work or I'm I'm I'm yeah
I'm out yeah out I'm not I'm not gonna
put up with it so my so my other
theories now do i what do i do do I just
date women who would pushovers you don't
a date there meeting them you know I
mean yeah what you want to be in that
relationship either no so it's it's a
yeah I I think guys like us and and many
people listening you have to acknowledge
when you're hard to live with yourself
yeah and that's that's something that
you got to work on you know do you do
stuff to work on if you ever like I got
a a and stuff right now to give a good
do anything like that
no I I gave up booze and everything for
almost a year
really yeah I realized until right now
he's still I'm no I'm not I'm drinking
no I'm not drunk right now
yeah but I'm drinking at the moment yeah
yeah yeah but I don't I don't hit it
anywhere near as hard as I used to but I
do have I do have problem with binge
drinking I have a problem of if I have a
have a ten beers I won another five you
know I've never I don't see any interest
in having two drinks you'll never you'll
never see me just go to the bar for one
mm-hmm I don't see the point in it I'll
go and have a water or something like
that but I'll never just if you offered
me a beer now it seems pointless to me
yeah but look these like getting mazed
it is almost by appointment you know I'd
like to get drunk and it seems such a
such a weird thing and Americans frown
upon it so badly but in LA they do like
the rest of America doesn't I get drunk
very rarely now very rarely do I get
drunk and you know a few times a month
and that might seem like a lot to people
but maybe three times a month right and
for me it's like I enjoyed that I don't
like the whole idea that you're not
allowed to do it it's like I'm not gonna
get drunk at Thanksgiving but I know
there's a lot of people thinking I'm
gonna get [ __ ] plastered for things I
have worked with next day and oh this
and you know that's cool that's cool
yeah it's fine they should be able to
they should be able to with no and also
I don't believe I've I've ever I'm not a
nasty drunk so yeah you know what's the
problem
yeah I remember I was on your podcast
and you were drinking that day and then
you sent me a nice message later and
just said thanks for coming it was like
a nice thing to do you know yeah and
you'd been drinking and I was like oh I
didn't think that you would do that it
was nice of you what does I mean if you
don't think that someone's gonna get
drunk and probably do something nice you
know sometimes yeah I shouldn't drink
but it is fun no it was great though
that was the best part of it was this do
you feel like people want to see you
drink though well that's the problem is
too sometimes you get people who I I one
of my pet hates is when I get accused of
being drunk when I'm not really so
someone comes and sees the show and the
writer if you like I didn't pay to see
some guys struggling around drunk drive
home
yeah I mean so like I had a salad yeah
yeah sometime and then and then
sometimes you play up to it a bit more
and people think the show is out of
control but you know exactly what's
going on yeah I mean so so it like
there's only probably three times in my
whole career where I was ashamed of the
level of drunkenness that I had but I've
done like 3,000 shows so I'm alright
without that is it
do you notice as your career gets bigger
and as you get like as a bigger voice
and stuff that do you feel more
responsibility to do like material
that's more important or do you just
feel like you're growing and changing in
well at the moment I'm not doing
anything political onstage because I do
so much of it on the TV show right that
I'm sort of political doubt and I'm
regressing back to the comic that I was
in my 20s like yeah I'm just telling
stories about dating bothering me in the
world and there's stuff about being a
dad but so degenerate dad stuff yeah I
mean like you know but I yeah I feel
like um I'm simplifying my stand-up a
lot more back to big stories but I like
it all right like the like the corner
piece of my new tour at the moment is a
thirty minute story about me [ __ ]
myself yeah okay thirty minutes but it's
so relatable dude and [ __ ] yourself
never takes less than 30 minutes cuz you
know it's one minute and then it stumped
twenty-nine minutes of bucking Titan
well there's only one minute the end of
the [ __ ] and the rest of its the
preamble to the [ __ ] and like the story
starts with I'm lactose intolerant so
you know the ending oh yeah and then the
rest of it is like an episode of Columbo
where you see the murderer to begin with
and then you have to figure out how we
got to there I love it what was the
moment you know I mean so I like [ __ ]
like that man there's a that reminds me
of that Dave Chappelle kick kick her in
the [ __ ] joke if you seen that where he
tells the punchline first yeah and then
he goes back and tell
whole story it's pretty great let's uh
do we have any more Nick that came in
yeah we have a couple more I have one
about the Jim Jefferies show you just
said like you kind of get sick of the
politics does it have is there something
in the show that has to be political or
no no no I don't get sick III don't get
sick of the politics doing it on the
show at all I just don't want to do it
on the weekends after I've been doing it
through the week yeah does the show have
to be political do you think it doesn't
have to be political and and maybe 50%
of our episodes have everything's
political first of all but have social
issues so if we want to talk about
health care or whatever like that or you
want to talk about something to do with
parks or whatever the [ __ ] it becomes
political but as for talking about what
the administration's up to now it
doesn't have to be and I believe that we
only talked about trumping about a third
of the episodes and what we're just
going to be use for all they do is talk
about Trump because that's all the
people that want to complain is saying
and that's what goes meow and that's
what goes viral and that's what gets the
variety of Hollywood Reporter writing an
article about your episode where they're
like oh and then I bring down with it
but then these things like Charlotte
VLEs Charlotte Charles Ville happens you
can't not talk about it that week yeah
right so Cavanaugh happens you have to
talk about that week otherwise what's
the point of what we're doing you know I
would rather talk about [ __ ] what's
happening in in lighter things we don't
want to talk about things that are heavy
your time because they're [ __ ] heavy
but you have to talk about things and
hopefully when you do you can lighten
the load a little bit and make the news
a bit more palatable for people that
have been watching seen in the whole
[ __ ] time or Fox it has been weighed
down with experts giving opinions well
yeah you're funny opinion yeah yeah or
at least here's something yeah I've
liked that the news has jumped the shark
too in America it's not even news
anymore is it the same is it the same in
Australia I bought forest to England
with me to do to do some gigs and he was
just he goes I can't figure out what's
wrong with the BBC news there's
something not quite right with it and I
go well they're not giving opinions that
is telling you what's happened yeah
don't bring on a panel of experts it's
all seen any supply expert that's panel
of expert the scene is the work it's
just panel panel panel panel panel and
they're all
yeah there are just people who are just
[ __ ] wannabe journalists or
journalists or [ __ ] whatever and
they're all experts yeah on what
all of them didn't [ __ ] think that ex
campaign managers or you know I mean
[ __ ] [ __ ] bro all of them didn't think
the Trump was even gonna win like that's
a crazy thing to me all these people all
these experts and then they had no idea
so it's like how out it's at that that's
when for a lot of people the news jumped
the shark it was like these people know
what the [ __ ] you're talking about
people think I got my sure people really
believe there's there's the Clintons are
paying guys like me money to talk out
against guns like they really believe
that's what's happening yeah
so I've done a load of rape jokes and
all of a sudden they went Hillary
Hillary we have the guy yeah we have the
guy that can really bring you over it's
rapey Jim Jefferies with these jokes you
know I mean like like it's very bizarre
to me that you know they would think
that I'd be the voice of whatever yeah
but what was I talking about I think
you're paid to talk people think you're
paid to give these opinions on all the
things but I had another point that was
more valid than that I [ __ ] it
slipped me that's all right let's go
back what was a of a second before that
we're talking about
oh I said um yeah them oh oh when we
when we started the show we were making
the pilot during the election and we
were about we had written a whole pilot
episode that was being filmed a couple
of days later that was all about Hillary
winning some people think that I got
this TV show to speak out against Trump
or something I got this TV show thinking
knowing that Hillary was going to be the
president right and writing Hillary
jokes that's what we were going to be
doing and then he wins and then we had
to go back to the office ago all right
well we're right now whole new episode
yeah cuz we never expected it I remember
sitting with all the writers in the room
and we were like arts alright yeah
she'll win Florida and then we all left
for the day yeah and then we started
texting each other short there was that
moment when he started to win when
you're like there was a little bit of
like holy [ __ ] this is gonna be
interesting yeah this is gonna you know
I wanted him to sort of come in and be
good yeah but there is there is like
the moment if he gets that thing with
people going to prison for long
sentences for his weed crimes mhm if he
gets that broad around no other like
really the the Democrats have nothing to
say about that because that was really
Clinton who [ __ ] did that and yeah or
that it was Reagan with the war on drugs
and so they sorted and then Clinton
brought in the terms right and now it's
like if Kanye West and Donald Trump if I
can get people out of prison that are in
there for [ __ ] life sentences for a
little bit of [ __ ] weed yeah and then
I wish I had my show this week so I
could congruent congratulate both oh no
no win again I mean I just the
interesting thing to me is just how out
of touch that how so much of the
Hollywood industry is there now second
third fourth generation Los Angeles and
New Yorkers and so they're not as in
touch with the rest of America and what
it's like to live in the rest of America
a lot of people in America aren't racist
a lot of people in America don't hate
Latinos don't hate gays I feel like
forty years ago twenty years ago I think
you had more of that but I don't think
you have that now I think you have just
a lot of this industry out here beating
those people down with that so much and
they're like whoo and they're walking
the ride aren't doing themselves favors
with things like Charlottesville and the
type of stuff and right people
protesting the caravan Trump plays in
today yeah he does I agree gives you he
gives you fears that you didn't know you
had that you're worried about this I'm
the only person who can fix it and
that's how you brainwash people is by
saying saying here's a problem you
didn't know your head but I can stop it
that's how you sell snake oil yeah you
[ __ ] do it oh yeah he's a dirty
business and dirty businessman no doubt
but I think America was ready to elect a
[ __ ] blueberry muffin they're just
tired I think people are just tired of
it they'd rather see they'd rather to
spend for themselves I think a lot of
people yeah what do you think is gonna
happen in the next election I think
Trump will win again in the next
elections I have a feeling he will as
well it won't be as like like his mind
said she won the popular vote
it'll be very close again yeah I think
it'd be very close again I just think
that like you're saying a lot more
people I think less people will vote
overall yes knowing let's pray we gotta
fight over all but but I worry about the
young people also getting you know have
19 kids 19 year old kids I mean I feel
like they should raise the voting age to
21 but if somebody can serve in the
military
they should be able to vote you know
that's only fair but it's just I feel
like now the biggest thing is
manipulating kids in a weird way and
getting them like you know I see both
both these parties going after young
people but I guess that's the way it's
always been you know yeah you got my 19
Yuans right yeah you can send him to
wall you should let him drink as well
yeah oh yeah well my state was the last
state you'll be proud that allowed 18
year-olds to drink Louisiana and they
wouldn't give us any federal highway
money for years because we wouldn't
raise it to 21 so not only could we
drink but we drank um [ __ ] broken
roads insane let's get a couple more so
we can get Jim out of here hey what's up
Co so my question is for Jim I had a I
guess for both of you guys was there
ever a point or what was the specific
point for either you or Co where you
kind of made the decision she start
bettering yourself and you actually
stuck to it when was the moment where it
really calcified and you guys to kind of
decided to turn it around and really
stuck to it I think you so much deal I
appreciate everything you do man Gang
Gang Gang well to better yourself I
don't know it's a I don't know if I've
done that I just feel like like old ages
made me make some decisions that had to
be done there wasn't a conscious you
know what I mean like like I've always
tried to better myself you know but I
don't regret who I was in my 20s I mean
it was a different guy but it was
somebody who needed to [ __ ] exist
them yeah make this guy you know I mean
like like I if I remained the same
there's nothing worse than a stand-up
comedian who was popular in their 20s
and then they're still trying to pull
off the same stick in their 50 it's a
really good point and it looks it looks
like and I won't name some names we know
some people who still wear the same
Williams still wear the same leather
jacket yeah I got insight right or even
like Dynes got a bit of that yeah yeah
yeah like to put the tight shirt on and
yeah we gotta age we were probably in
Schmitt shirt sometimes yeah and there's
some comics I would say though who are
in danger this is about to happen to
them and I didn't want that to be me you
know I know I lose fans everyday people
like you I used to like that but you
hope you pick people up along the way
right you know I mean because my ticket
sales are still the same as they've
always been but I can see the shift in
the audience and who are coming to see
me and I just think if I was just like
doing you know I was [ __ ] some [ __ ]
after a [ __ ] if I still buy that stuff
which seem like an angry [ __ ] drunk
20 year old which is what I was and I
would look kind of sad now yeah yeah it
is I mean I think you have to be you
have to be brave to recognize that I
mean and to notice how to be aware of it
you know not yeah and and it's also
brave to try and evolve because that's
risky you realize it's some stage with a
lot of things that you were angry at you
like what was i fighting for no no don't
even no one is angry and then and I'm
sure I look back in when I'm 70 at this
age now and go what was I worried about
I was constantly worried me too
yeah I'm always worried I want to get to
a size because my father was a big
wearing and now he doesn't worry at all
he's life's trivial and he's not trivial
he's just had the most trivial [ __ ] my
father keeps a slingshot right gonna
sling shots right yeah bunnies bunnies
table next to his recliner yeah and he
has the door though because all these
cockatoos and lorikeets these big
indigenous a stream oh yeah the
lorikeets man it lorikeets a beautiful
car for birds and cockatoos these big
white birds with the yellow sort of
that's awesome they have Omar's Birds on
Wilshire and I saw some over there and
so they just fly around in my dad's
house he leaves some birdseed out there
and the same birds come and visit all
time you guys but sometimes the
cockatoos come in and there is the
lorikeets and they take the lorikeets
the lorikeets food and so my dad keeps a
slingshot to shoot the birds and the
balcony and he goes yeah they sort of
fly off as it hits them they don't die
it's the same one but that's like how
his life is now he's trying to fend for
these birds to get enough free food off
him and the cockatoos are is enemy Wow I
think I wouldn't have eaten on them yeah
you like that that's a simple life here
that's a guy's not
right about a lot yeah yeah I can't talk
at the moment the the cockatoos are
bothering the lower case there'll be a
great name for a special years I feel
like but cockatoos are bothering
Lawrence do you have any video questions
that came in yep all right let's hit one
hey Theo it's Johnny from Kentucky I
don't know that man obviously sitting in
a video for your guests I just wanted to
ask why he's so salty about basically
everything in the United States no story
though so I don't want to say too much
about it I was just curious it seems
like he always has something kind of
negative to say all the time anyways
I'll be there at your show and Lexington
super stoked about it gonna bring out
the wife good times
awesome man it'll be great thanks for
the question yes right in typical
American do you hate America no day at
America and it's what I lived in the UK
all I talked about was UK politics or
something like that and because I have a
different views on the Second Amendment
doesn't mean that I hate America right I
just did a little piece in The Hollywood
Reporter today where I talked about
becoming a citizen I don't have any no I
don't hate America oh man America's
given me many opportunities that I
wouldn't have had without America
yeah and it's and I've amassed wealth
and and I've had a child and I've get to
you know of course I love a man you feel
like the American dream a little bit I
feel I feel it's a stupid statement in
the sense that it's the same dream that
anybody in any free country has you know
the same thing that straight work hard
and your chief goals right I mean and
that's the same in Britain the same as
you know Canada has the same dream you
know it's it's you've just branded it a
lot better right but I do believe in
that ideal I believe that working hard
and achieving goals and doing right by
people and all those type of things that
eventually you can succeed but do I hate
America no more than I hate Australia
and I have my issues with Australia no
more than I hate Britain where I live
for 10 years as well I I think this idea
that I I I believe that being true
patriotism being being truly patriotic
means being speaking out against your
government or
trying to find flaws I believe being
patriotic doesn't mean you follow
blindly whatever your government tells
you to do and then you stand when you're
told to stand yeah I believe taking a
knee can be as patriotic an activity is
standing for the national anthem so
that's where I sit on the matter I you
know people might not agree with that
but but act like I'm so salty I say so
these words are very good because I have
a late-night talk show news based talk
so of course I have to I can't go on
about Australian politics the whole
[ __ ] time yeah I have to mention the
world that's around me and also I do get
[ __ ] off at the no health care thing
and on cyber stuff because you know I
grew up in a different world than that
you know but I tell you what the lobster
here is the best I love [ __ ] baseball
I love pinball machines yeah I like the
women enough do you know to me I don't
like we're allowed to say anything
positive about the government though
these days you can no of course you can
say positive things about the government
it doesn't mean that you're you're not
patriotic or you are patriotic if you do
either are either I just find that that
is a distinctly American thing because
I've complained about Britain live there
and I never got a complaint and I can
complain about Australian things and
Australians don't kick back on me too
much yeah but Americans do have this
there is a there is something about when
you you had to stand for a flag your
entire life and pledge allegiance to it
that you have this when especially when
a foreigner says something where you
have this [ __ ] you attitude but you're
allowed to be criticized you know you're
not an individual you know I'm
criticizing mass companies and
governments and groups yeah you know
you're not an individual it's not like
I've just come over here and you're just
one person I've called you fat right
which is still laughs yeah yeah if that
is say i i i'm not i'm i'm all for fat
shaming yeah
I'm all for fat shaming and I've just
come to terms with this recently yeah
because I was a little bit PC and this
is well like I don't know yeah fat no no
I'm [ __ ] fat shame away man whenever
I get a bit overweight its somebody's
saying one comment that makes me go
around a bit of lose weight to think of
all the addictions or all the vices I've
had in my life whether it be nicotine
alcohol
any drugs or whatever food has been the
biggest one for me really the food has
been the one where I have problems with
food i stiii more than coke and stein
yeah i crashdïet on food and then I
[ __ ] fatten up again and then I get
thin again and up and down and it's like
you know what man I go into restaurants
and I use restraint I ever order what I
[ __ ] want i order the third thing I
want you know I mean and that's that's
just me being mildly fat the third thing
I want if I was a real committed person
I'd pick the thing that I least want and
I would [ __ ] yeah the burgers would
be the same I want the pasta before the
burger all right I want a mac and cheese
or something and I can't have that
that's fat guy activity yeah okay I will
have the burger the burger still and
then I finished with like I will have a
salmon with a couscous and a thing and
it's like it's only dropping my 100
calories on each thing and I'm still
doing it with the [ __ ] creamy sauce
on it or whatever that white sauce yeah
but I'm still calm I'm not quite getting
what I want here right so I believe that
any other addiction whether it be heroin
or cocaine or something like that or
cigarettes definitely people will shame
the [ __ ] out with shame the [ __ ] out of
you you excuse me he's smoking this is
like I have to walk the same street as
you or are you doing heroin
oh yeah well yeah I like like heroin
like look at yourself you're a [ __ ]
disgrace cocaine you're [ __ ] dumb
cokehead Yeah right but if you go oh
you're fat can't stop eating so much
sugar then you're an evil person it's
still addiction still addiction and we
we're shaming every other addiction
we're shaming every other one except for
this one yeah and we could go the other
way let's not shame any of the other
ones
let's not shame anybody wouldn't that be
a wonderful world if no one was shamed
yeah but we feel as a society we need to
shame people to make a difference so
here's the thing if you're fat you're
[ __ ] overeating you eat too much
sugar I throw stuff there is a secret to
it you know how to stop exercise and
what you [ __ ] died you will live
longer and people but people will say to
you when you're dragging they will say
they will say you have a child
do you have a dish how [ __ ] day but
no one no one woke up to a fat person go
you will die at a young age how dare you
you're a mother you're a father
yeah I mean and they should have as much
right to say that make sure nobody comes
up to your Dunkin Donuts and says you
put that you have twins yeah [ __ ] yeah
yeah they put on the side of cigarette
packets in in Britain and Australia
pictures of people who have lost their
foot no you see I've never met a single
person who's lost a foot from cigarettes
yeah show me the lung cancer picture
show me anything I've never met the foot
guy I've never met the guy hobbling
around I was a smoker I'm sure it exists
so I'd send me photos cuz I'm sure it
exists but I know several people have
lost a foot to sugar yeah
several bit and true and you haven't on
the side of a coke can put a [ __ ]
stump yeah the [ __ ] shame me as I
drink this sugar which is an addictive
substance I reckon it's as addictive as
cocaine when given to mice or rats or
some sugars the new caffeine man sugars
the new nicotine I mean it really is
yeah people are so like sugars crazy
people don't realize it's killing people
eating their skin it's eating your
grandmother out from the inside right
now not in a [ __ ] good way either
you know it's killing senior citizens
everywhere yes sugar the sugar man and
and so I'm all for fat shaming and I'm
saying this is an overweight person yeah
I'm not I don't consider myself fat but
I'm overweight oh jeez fella your arms
looks you know they look like they could
be stronger could have a little bit of
fat on but also strong a little
something so some of that's but some of
that you have a natural like your
strength to you don't you yeah yeah yeah
and that's Australian
all right Austrian drew the toughest
people I've traveled around the world of
decent amount every time it's the
toughest people that are always like
that just like it's like a tornado and
it's always Australians Australians go
everywhere
Australians are in everywhere it's
amazing to me that if you go to like
Whistler all the ski instructors are
Australian yeah like couldn't we get
Canadians today's we've got the guys
from the hot country well again teach
you how to ski it always dance with
their the bunny slaves and now you all
ready for death mains reaching it's
always like a [ __ ] yeah cuz they
always Australians they're always I feel
like they're all like just I see a baby
bottle with Red Bull in it and they're
all about to jump off the side of the
[ __ ] crib with wings oh yeah I tell
you what
with his giant like Australian actors
and there there is you know theatrical
as anybody yeah but we make like the Mel
Gibson's the Hemsworth's the Russell
Crowe's I think we make men yeah we make
men in the acting world even our more
musical men a [ __ ] Hugh Jackman and
Hugh Jackman so talented yeah and he
said but he's still [ __ ] Wolverine we
make man yeah and then Britain gives you
[ __ ] now you pop Hugh Grant Jude Law
they give you men but they don't give
you a man they give you sponges yeah you
know I mean they give you blithering
idiots give you poor people who like I'm
sorry I even Tom Ford Brant not tough
guys not talk about Australia give you
tough guys and Americans give you just
do she bloody actors yeah well I give us
action stars we give you we give you
muscle bad guys though yeah oh yeah yeah
yeah you give us bad guys also the
sterile I don't even that was an
Austrian that really pushed that was it
oh yeah he was Australian not Austrian
no he's Austria he come in but he
studies a black Austrian
uh just he's so muscular no I think what
Americans have given some we gave we
given over the years Oh Brad Pitt Brad
Pitt man but is pity a tough go easy is
cleaning pick tough no no they're not
they're kind of like they like suave you
give suave we got our guys are guys that
you'll see at the spa we can't give you
we can't give you cool
we give you tough Daniel what's that
Daniel would say the legend crying now
yeah he's British she's British yeah
yeah but he's small and tough what be
Welsh actually yeah they're [ __ ] posh
aren't they the Welsh yeah no where's
Newcastle New Castle's in England dude I
saw something new I saw some things in
Newcastle I'll never forget man
large eyes you just brought a Burt
Reynolds that's your toughest guy Burt
Reynolds maybe was younger would have
played Freddie Mercury in the movie
right now like that's that's the guy
that you want to give me Burt Reynolds
hey we got Frankie Muniz to pull up
Frankie Muniz if you don't mind but like
like a Lego
and and checkmate Michael Landon yeah do
you have your mic you gave is Rock
Hudson yeah Hudson was your toughest guy
bringing you news are out of this is
hollywood's new toughest guy right here
this little you see back Frank he's not
see black I mean blacks Frankie Muniz
is he back um I don't know whose wife
looks was actually a really nice guy I
didn't mean something anymore we're good
we have one more one more put it through
he's guys jerking off or not maybe I
hope hey Theo hi Jim big fan of you guys
from me from Chile I was wondering if
either of you have any plans of ever
doing a South American tour I think that
you would find there are a lot of big
venues and a lot of a lot of other fans
of both of you and I would [ __ ] love
to see you both
big fan to get up and get in there get
in there
South America is any place I haven't gig
Wow in the world yeah everywhere else
about these like Asian gigs and stuff
I've never been I just there's something
about South America and this my next
place I want to travel I guess but
there's something about it it always
always feels like it's going to be
dangerous yeah you gotta be pickpocketed
the whole time oh yeah
and I was nothing like a just a bad
stereotype I might is being a no I got
it I went to Brazil once and I got
pickpocketed by a woman and she and I
got a fist fight the only woman I've
ever you know been legally allowed to
fight and uh and it was pretty I don't
know if I wouldn't say anybody won but
it was [ __ ] there was no winner yeah
yeah but yeah but I did that's what
happened to my got pickpocketed but I
have a big but I think I get
pickpocketed a lot again got paid
pocketed in Prague one time and I got
pickpocketed in um and now actually in
Minneapolis outs out of the airport so
Minneapolis yeah you pick but it's not a
hub for it is it I don't know I've been
once in Sydney I was mugged oh yeah yeah
garden knife give me your wallet I think
if you could go back in time would you
do it differently no no there you go
good luck right you have a new tour you
going on a new tour Jim
I'm yeah I'm doing new material from my
last like like that's not on my last
special you know it's called the night
talker to her and that was you know that
yet the name I'm too little pain in the
ass and I was like I was literally
watching a thing in the Nightstalker
like a document oh wow when they rang me
up how the night talk that's a girl in
dude
but yeah I'm about boys dry but then I'm
about to ease these prices and I yeah
Korea Taiwan Thailand well we're doing
field pieces for the TV show because
that's that's the big thing my show has
that the other shows don't have I do my
own Phil pieces and so that's why we do
less episodes because I'm off filming
the Philby's
and how Phil pieces are all
international Wow the daily show does
[ __ ] just ones in America for the
most part and they've got like [ __ ]
five people I do all my own ones so
we're going to go out to Asia and we're
going to be there for 18 days and we're
going to record nine Phil pieces and and
do like 10 shows in you're a dual
citizen now do you think that your life
ends with you having a citizenship or
exile how does it end
I think the ends of the citizen shout
out and see me being excited see I I I
think I think like on your own island I
think when I'm really old there's a part
of me that because maybe I'll go back to
where I was born like an elephant yeah
you know go but but it's like it all
depends on what my son is doing with his
life and how close we remain in the
sense that it will he be you know he
might get married and live in
Connecticut with some woman and then
it's like by that stage it's like I
might as well live in Australia and if
he visits me in the same amount of times
you know me I'm not gonna be one of
these weird parents it's gonna hold my
child back or or travel to whatever city
he lives in you know yeah so so for me I
I just the next phase of my life I guess
thirteen years from now and my son's 18
I think I think I'll probably have
another little shift or in a little term
but who knows I I can see myself being
retired by then as well oh I think we
can say [ __ ] honestly yeah that is
my family that I didn't know my god
don't know really I don't know if I'll
be doing stand-up in
to my 60s do you see us yeah do you see
a second career in you that you think I
would like to focus more on the TV if I
if I could get acting work I'd get it
but I don't get offered much really yeah
it's funny I could see it kind of a
little bit like kind of like a Good Will
Hunting Grant but of Good Will Hunting I
could be the actual janitor because
that's just writing gibberish on the
wall I know I'd like this man I feel
like maybe producing or something like
that getting in behind the scenes a bit
more I could do but I don't know if I
could you know I've been doing theaters
now for maybe eight years yeah I don't
know if I could go back to going into a
comedy club because I've never heard of
anyone going theatres comedy club back
to the--let's yeah so so on the way down
I don't think I would let it go that
long I think I I don't know you know
seven or eight specials and I'll
probably record another two once you get
to ten it's like how many jokes do you
wonder if I can tell the world yeah it's
like if people like yeah there's all the
back catalogue to watch The Beatles
brought at [ __ ] ten albums and then
after that they broke up now writing
songs by themselves and no one gave a
[ __ ] yeah I mean like still well one was
in the Traveling Wilburys I think at one
point I might know that uh brief second
do you feel bad sometimes like I noticed
like sometimes you'll have fans that are
really excited and then you actually
meet them and you feel like you're a
letdown like in awesome all the time all
the time and it's it's you know I I get
a lot of people who come up and get I
can't and you like or I try I just want
to call you a [ __ ] anyway see in the
u.s. where people aren't definitely I do
a meet-and-greet after the show but just
for people who bought like the front two
rows you know because I used to do a
meet and greet with the entire audience
and it used to take like two hours and
that's what I've been doing and it's
this draining me brutal it's Brett but
it when you get to like six like what
soon as you buy a hundred thousand no no
no I meant like maybe selling two
thousand tickets a weekend I'm still in
clubs just starting to do some theaters
right you're saying selling 2,000
tickets right so you're going to go
you're about to go up to like these
eight hundred nine hundred seat theaters
and then it's still manageable because
like 200 people stay behind
you went through but then when you go to
like anything over a thousand seats but
he start like four hundred people start
waiting in line
it's like takes you a long time and you
got to give them all a little moment you
know yeah and so I just once the
theaters got over sort of two thousand
three thousand seats i I just said I'll
do a meet and greet if you know people
the first couple were the first couple
of rows who bought the tickets first
before everyone else yeah and so I like
that yeah so you do that and then but
even then people get a little bit
disappointed cuz sometimes you're
exhausted and it is like being Santa
Claus like people come in one at a time
and yeah I want to be nice to them you
want to be nice to but if I if I've had
a few drinks that I can chat and be very
thing but if I haven't then I am shy in
that situation it is a very shy
situation to be in because you're like
did you enjoy the show thank you and
sometimes we'll be honest but I've seen
you four times did you enjoy so well
this one wasn't as good as the last
night yeah and then like like there just
think it is talking and your little
heart goes huh well I put a lot of
effort into it huh okay and then you
thinking about that for the next five
people that come up is it weird I'm
starting to find that I can tell in the
first five minutes if a show is gonna be
awesome or fritzsche of course yeah you
can tell within the first two minutes
you can do things to pick up the pace
you can get them back you can you know
they're the real triumphs is when the
audience is [ __ ] and then you work and
work and work and then like the last 20
minutes is good that still classifies as
a bad joke yeah because we've just done
an hour and 10 that wasn't enjoyable for
any of us and then towards the end you
went well we better start enjoying
ourselves at times running out yeah and
so and I've also had ones where the
audience has been great and then I've
been a little bit complacent with that
and I've lost them and had to get them
back again you know you go I like what
you think I'm not gonna give him all the
a stuff because there's such a good
crowd I'll give him some new stuff that
I've been thinking about and I'll give
him the a stuff later on in the show but
I'll just you know this guy's so hot I
can't write this new stuff and then the
new stuff isn't that good and you lose
them and you're like yeah [ __ ] and then
you want to say look that's new that's
new that's not my best stuff I got stuff
coming up I know it's fun though is it
still fun it is still find the
traveling's lost
all of its luster and hotel rooms but
there I still the best part of my day is
still the show yeah that's the bit
that's the bit I look forward to all day
so that says something right I think so
you know you still get I still get I
still get excited when I'm driving up
the theater and I see a lot of people
around the block
you still think wow because I remember
the first time that happened to me and I
remember thinking oh there must be other
people that another show in here you
know I mean and I thought like 200
people have bought tickets is there and
I saw like 900 or something Muffy
Whitesnake or something yeah and I was
like why that was for me yeah you know I
yeah I feel good
of course yeah cause it does yeah it's
still it's still validates you whether
it shouldn't yeah but it still makes you
feel wonderful yeah it's it makes you
feel loved as well and it shouldn't make
you feel that way but that's wrong with
us dick to quote to quote Cool Runnings
if you're not enough with it you won't
be enough without it yeah right but I I
I'm at this moment I'm not enough
without it yeah and I hope to reach a
zen-like state where I am but normal
citizen guys Jim Jefferies thanks so
much for being here yeah really
appreciate it
[Music]
but when I reach that round I'll share
this piece of my I can feel it thought
it's gonna take
little time for me to sell that parking
brake
[Music]